oggi sono qui per raccontarvi una storia
una storia che parla di storytelling
mattoncini lego
questa storia ha una protagonista una
protagonista principale che sono io
eccomi la storia che riguarda antonio
quando antonia nel suo ufficio riceve
una telefonata era una giornata normale
di lavoro una come tante lavorando al
computer ea quel punto riceve la
telefonata di matteo matteo mi invita a
parlare qui con voi alta ed ex della
metodologia né così display una
metodologia sulla quale mi sono
certificata da poco questa metodologia
riguarda una possibilità che viene data
alle aziende di lavorare sulla
rappresentazione delle dinamiche e delle
questioni che appartengono alle aziende
in tutte le loro situazioni classiche
utilizzando proprio il modello le
mattoncini lego
perché perché rappresentano una metafora
una metafora sulla quale si può lavorare
si può comunque interpretare in qualche
maniera è quindi è stata studiata e
costruita da importanti esperti una vera
e propria progettualità che si può
realizzare all'interno delle aziende per
lavorare sul metodo leggo serious play
quindi sostanzialmente viene applicata a
una eterogeneità di attività e
possibilità che vanno dalla
re crudi ma anche il team building
lavorare sul decisio making problem
solving
si tratta e si definisce questa
metodologia una metodologia senza
contenuto perché una metodologia
trasversale che si può applicare proprio
ai contesti in maniera indipendente
perché la il contenuto dell'attività
dipende dalla domanda che l'azienda pone
al facilitatore certificato che guiderà
le sessioni di gruppo per realizzare
diciamo la soluzione è progettare
l'evento e dall'altra parte dipende
anche dalle competenze che facilitatore
a e che propone quindi in questo senso
antonia ha ricevuto la sua chiamata è
stata invitata a parlare delle voci
display però che cosa interviene
intervengono loro due scheletrini a
questo punto cioè esiste il problema di
capire come spiegare a un pubblico che
non ho mai sentito probabilmente parlare
della metodologia qualcosa che è più
facile da capire facendolo il motto
della metodologia è pensa con le tue
mani
quindi si pensa facendo è difficile da
raccontare
allora a quel punto la mia idea è stata
mettiamo insieme lo storytelling che è
l'altro focus importante di cui mi
occupo da tanti anni con la metodologia
leggo e proviamo cioè a costruire una
storia qui dentro in questa sfera non so
se si vede ci sono sia i pezzetti leggo
che le testoline delle persone le loro
esperienze le storie e quindi questo è
diventato il centro del mio talk mettere
insieme solidali nei mattoncini però a
quel punto c'è stato un altra questione
la prima sfida cioè
andare a confrontarsi con una struttura
complicata e complessa perché perché
guarda caso esattamente nello stesso
giorno in cui era stato pianificato
l'evento che noi oggi abbiamo in corso
io avevo programmato un altro evento con
un'azienda che vedete qui rappresentata
con questa struttura grigia e polverosa
ho messo la ragnatela
c'è un ragnetto e tutte le persone sopra
vedete non si guardano c'è anche il
nostro leader
quella sua corona perché non è un vero
leader è un po qualcuno che si è messo
in testa di poter comandare
allora io dovevo trovare una soluzione
con loro per provare a cambiare data
non poteva essere così difficile eppure
se vedete le cose non girano queste
ruote non trovano la soluzione sembra
che la trovino ma non girano le cose non
funzionano e io rimango impantanata in
quello che sembra essere un po un incubo
di non riuscire a combinare la soluzione
a un problema semplice
a quel punto quello che trovo come
modalità è mettere tutte le persone
intorno a un tavolo e farle comunicare
nella nell'azienda grigia e polverosa le
persone non ci guardano e non parlano
fra di loro all'interno della sessione
in cui vengono messo intorno a un tavolo
a trovare la soluzione a quel punto le
cose girano ed effettivamente una
soluzione si riesce a trovare poteva
essere molto semplice ci sono voluti
solo due mesi però alla fine è andato
tutto bene sembrava tutto a posto c'era
il topic del talk c'era la data
c'era la mia disponibilità a partecipare
il mio interesse
però è intervenuto un altro problema un
problema un po più complicato a questo
punto
eccolo mia madre si ricovera in ospedale
a quel punto tutte le varie priorità che
potevano riguardare il talk la
presentazione e le chicche stesse slide
ovviamente diventano assolutamente
secondarie perché io vengo richiamata in
una situazione in cui la priorità per me
essere di aiuto trovare la modalità per
andare a salerno dalla madre stare
vicino a lei in ospedale e capire
valutare l'entità dei rischi e della
situazione quindi è evidente che io ho
messo completamente in stand by
l'attenzione per il talk per dedicarmi a
tutt'altro e non sapevo fino a che punto
sarei potuta essere qui oggi
dipendeva ovviamente da una serie di
variabili che dovevo essere in grado di
coniugi gestite di controllare però a un
certo punto le cose sono andate un po
meglio infatti oggi sono comunque sono
riuscita a venire con la macchina da
salerno a roma e dall'uomo ad assisi per
condividere con voi un insieme di
conoscenze le esperienze partecipare
ascoltare a quello che è comunque una
nuova visione una possibilità di avere
input e di avere insight da
un'esperienza arricchente come quella
che può essere il tex e quindi a questo
punto che cosa decido decido che da
buona subacquea posso tuffarmi
nell'esperienza del teteks e posso
partecipare
essendo qui con voi a contribuire a
raccontarvi questa metodologia è tutto
quello che le appartiene
quindi il nostro trasferimento e poi il
tuffo all'interno dell'anno la
prospettiva e dell'esperienza the next
perché è stato così importante questo
racconto perché ho scelto di raccontare
in questa modalità la mia esperienza con
la metodologia perché innanzitutto è
stato fondamentale per me costruire il
racconto del talk proprio in andando a
ripercorrere quelle che sono le
caratteristiche della metodologia leggo
sito e sprechi che come dicevo
sottolinea la capacità di pensare con le
mani io ho costruito la rappresentazione
del talk da presentare quindi ho seguito
quello che sono i principi dello
storytelling abbiamo sostanzialmente
attraversato quello che viene chiamato
lo schema del viaggio dell'eroe il
viaggio dell'eroe che parte dalla
chiamata che abbiamo visto all'inizio
con la telefonata del nostro matteo e
che poi attraversa una prima sfida una
battaglia finale chiamiamola così poi la
mia madre se lo sapesse è poi la nuova
prospettiva e quindi arrivare alla
diciamo al re worthing al momento
diciamo delle apl della nostra storia
dall'altra parte è stato una modalità
semplice ovviamente anche molto
semplificata di farvi vedere come
normalmente lavoriamo con la metodologia
quando lavoriamo nelle aziende noi
entriamo e cerchiamo di organizzare dei
gruppi di lavoro in cui le persone si
mettono intorno a un tavolo a costruire
a lavorare alla loro problematica
costruendo modellini leggo ma non è così
semplice perché si lavora
sostanzialmente su metafore sulla
riflessione sul input che viene dalle
metà
ma dall'altra parte la cosa interessante
è che in quante riunioni voi avete visto
partecipare davvero tutti erano tutti
coinvolti o c'era qualcuno che si stava
distraendo qualcuno che pensava altro
qualcuno che non contribuiva davvero
solitamente quando si parla di me di
questa metodologia si definisce la liga
e la persona quella che è un po in
disparte ma che probabilmente se fosse
davvero coinvolta nell'attività potrebbe
produrre un cambiamento potrebbe portare
un'idea nuova
una nuova visione allora questa
metodologia si dice che è 100 100
in questa metodologia noi abbiamo il
coinvolgimento sempre di tutti non c'è
nessuno che si tira indietro
abbiamo recuperato la dimensione del
gioco ma perché abbiamo deciso che nel
lavoro e nelle aziende il gioco dovesse
essere un elemento da tenere fuori forse
non è così vero
se noi giochiamo dentro l'azienda
facendo capire e comprendere la serietà
del nostro gioco
questo viene percepito e le persone i
manager tutti i team con cui abbiamo
lavorato ci sono resi conto che questo
lavoro non è un lavoro che serve solo a
sbloccare le potenzialità degli
impiegati rispetto ad abilità creative
la creatività è solo uno degli elementi
potremo guardare i mattoncini vederli
colorati e pensare di essere soltanto in
una modalità di gioco e di creatività ma
noi lavoriamo su dimensioni che possono
essere anche molto articolate molto
complesse e riusciamo a far emergere
quello che normalmente non emerge perché
ci sono barriere cognitive perché
normalmente noi non siamo abituati a ad
avere questo tipo di dimensione di
partecipazione
abbiamo quindi una capacità di lavorare
su una
una metodologia che davvero riesce ad
aumentare ad arricchire la performance
del business perché noi abbiamo trovato
una modalità per parlare con le persone
e fargli raccontare delle storie
autentiche questo è poi il link
fondamentale che volevo fosse il focus
del network perché lo storytelling
quando noi lavoriamo nelle aziende
cercando di chiedere alle aziende alle
persone di narrare la loro storia
autentica normalmente la prima storia
che esce non è quella giusta
la prima storia è una storia quella che
si vende nel marketing quella che
racconta le belle parole quella che la
gente si vuole sentir dire ma andare a
lavorare sulla storia autentica
significa fare un lavoro diverso lavoro
in profondità allora e mezzo i
mattoncini vengono definiti come dei
veri e propri astori maker tool riescono
a essere la parte che costruisce la
storia
io non devo averla già in mente la
storia la storia nasce facendola allora
a quel punto noi possiamo capire che se
vogliamo lavorare all'interno di un di
un'azienda di un break con un brand per
andare a costruire nuove storie
guardarle queste sole capire anche se
solo quello che davvero volevo
raccontare perché potrei scoprire che
invece questa storia che ho trovato in
fondo non è quella che davvero voglio
raccontare
allora forse trovo le parole per
cambiarla però l'ho guardata ho avuto
l'occasione anche non frequente di
andare a costruire con la metodologia
una vera e propria storia abbiamo due
quindi andare a fare a creare la
combinazione quella che serve per creare
e cambiare la storia
semplicemente costruendo un modello ma
anche potendolo cambiare noi abbiamo
diverse tecniche che utilizziamo in
questa metodologia perché noi
utilizziamo la metodologia per lavorare
sugli individui ma anche sui team e
sull'inter place nel suo insieme e
declinando di volta in volta anche la
tipologia di domanda che il facilitatore
certificato pone ai gruppi per lavorare
con loro ogni volta noi abbiamo dei
livelli di complessità di modelli che
cambiano e che sono ogni volta
differenti e che ogni volta daranno
anche un feedback molto diverso ci sono
alla base di questa metodologia molti
studi che hanno a che fare con la
psicologia quella pedagogia molti
elementi che hanno fondato la capacità
proprio di recuperare nella dimensione
del gioco dei mattoncini qualcosa che
sembrava che dovesse appartenere solo
all'infanzia invece se recuperiamo
quindi ritorniamo alla semplicità
possiamo provare a trovare una diversa
modalità di lettura e di narrazione
quindi in questo senso noi possiamo
spingere per puntare con le mani e
costruire una nuova storia